Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to POPGOES! Now we're gonna get right into it and we're gonna figure out
How to beat this but we got a lot of people that are in our face. I'm sorry for the delay...
Again with Pax West and preparing for the new tour- by the way the tour.
Ticket sales are underway. You can check that out in the description below and find if we're coming near your city
Uh it's just markiplier.com.
But now I have to once again re-remember everything that I've now forgotten
over the duration that I have not been playing this game, and then apply to this game that I don't even know what I'm doing.
Red eyes. I'm seeing things. Or did I?
Aw, crap... Aw, crap I don't even remember this call. Mwah, shitty dukes
Fritz: I've just got some notes, not a script-
[Mark cuts call]
Mark: I've already got this. Alright alright got it. I already got it. It's already on her way. Vent camera heat that bad boy up
Take a look out that window
There a Badger in there? No? Okay. Alright so long as I got this underway
Everything SHOULD be okay, cause this isn't that bad
It's pretty bad but not that bad. So you gonna move you Weasel
bastard? You're gonna move your boot? You gonna scooch? You go scooch away to the art room? C'mon do so- Oh he scooched...
Where'd you scooch too?
Where did you-
Oh I don't like that
Okay you're good. Okay got it got it
Fuckin' hell there was something under my desk. Something touched my foot under my desk! Gave me a bright spook!
Alright what do we got? What does am I supposed to be looking for? I completely forgot
I've already missed him?
Did I already miss him? Where'd you go- Oh, hey Badger you better get out of there. Where is he, where is he? Oh no
Badger what are you doing? Blue?
Dedushk. Ah I gotcha. Alright welp I'm getting panicked. No one there? Oh hey buddy oh 'scuse me?
Sorry. Pardon. Whaaa
Let me just CALMLY look out that window. What a serene depiction of the world around me. Oh I missed him didn't I
Oh freaky- AUUGH!!! God dammit foam's falling down from my wall!
Everything's going wrong
I-I swear to god foam just started to fall down on my wall. Eww
This is weird someone touched my foot and some foams coming down. I don't- I don't like either of that
I'm- I am actually thrown off right now
cause I... Ahhhh
shit well he's there still there ah he went already, gone part... AGHH ok
Panicking I'm panicking I don't need to panic. I don't actually need to panic. Fu- I forgot (Mark noises)
Okay alright it's fine. Just don't panic he's gonna deliver his doodle-ooh
He can deliver a few more doodle-oos before I- lose my goddamn mind.
Okay but all that being said I need to check when he gets back there and manage my panic
Doodly-doo. Scoodly-doo.
Okay
sTOP- It's sliding off the wall!! It's gonna fall down at any moment
Ahhh!
It's so weird it's just euggh
Fuck. This is not a calming situation here. This is not exactly what I was going for when I said
Did- When I-I didn't say anything that this was gonna be like a calming scenario but whatever it's still falling
Ah where is he? Shut down you- vent camera are you in there yet? Are they in there?
No they're not in there yet. They haven't even- muhaaaaaaaa
It's going it's gone it's gone it's gone.
Okay it's not gone..
Where'd he go? Ah shit
AH my light! GOD I told you, it knocked my light down! Well I guess I'm just like this from now on
Ugh I- It got real spoopy up in here oh boy welp alright
Gotta- I've just gotta deal, just gotta deal with it right? I just gotta deal with it ahhh
They're gone now - okay are they in the vent yet? No, they're not in that vent  - okay he's going towards the birthday room!
It's not like- no it's no indication of where -  ah shit! Oh?
That birthday room it's a different angle. That's what it is! It's a different angle so that's why it doesn't make any sense to me.
Then. No. Then. Have they moved yet? Probably not.
He's going towards?
Oh so that does give an indication of where he's going so if I learn what those rooms are then I will be better off.
Righty-oh right we go...
He's in there. Heat that up. What are you doing? What color are you doing are you going- Shit I missed him where'd he go?
Ah!
No goddamnit! He already got It. Man he's quick on that printer. Okay, what color? Green and boink okay got it.
♪Multitasking Is my favorite thing♪
Multi-tasking is
my favorite thing. Okay where are the girls?
I don't think they've made it past there yet have they? Or are they gonna steal my phone any second now?
Alright where is he? Is he back yet?
Okay he's going to the birthday room. Okay I know the birthday room is number one.
Okay. Okay. Birthday room is number one. Shut that down.
Easy-peasy, easy- easy lemon squeeze me. I got this even though it's really dark and spooky now, I got this.
Everybody's panicking I'm not panicking going to the birthday room again - oh tough shit for you because
I shut that down.
I think they might have gone to a different vent- Oh shit. Oh where did you come from.
Don't see them in any of those...oh? How did you get there that quickly!?
That was fasty foo! Okay the art room knows that- is that the art room
I don't know but I'ma learn the art room is real right now.
Art room? Yeah. That's the art room. Why is the art room full of arcades...
ugh, I don't know
(Mark noises)
This is the spoopiest eeeepisode... Yeah, all right I got this.
oh shh-ooty shoot where'd he go? Ahh no.
Geouh- Yeah okay, vent, heat, vent? You move okay you no move yet. They're real slow tonight they are real slow
and that's good for me. Work in my favor.
(mumbles)
God, so fast! Who knew badgers were that speedily!
Also there is that other printing room that he doesn't go to.
But that- oh shit did I miss him? oh god damn it.
Oh god damn it oh damn! Oh I did! Ah frick frick frick frick. Frick me he's going to the birthday room OOooh?
Okay gotta calm down. Every thing is fine.
Everything's fine.
All right he's going back to the birthday room.
Got him. Got ya keep that up! Okay so the-the-the basic strategy is he always got to return to the center first.
You-you got to get the camera there so you can see where he's going. Oaah! God damn it how did I miss you
In the vent!? Oh?
Frick that's not gooood! That's not good at all! Welp I'm dead.
Huughh.
I'm panicking!
How did I miss them? Where the heck do they come from? Where the heck did they go?
Oh excus' thats my brain. Alright well-
Ok alright! Well I'm back. Fixed that problem!
Ah man I-I-I-I don't know why I missed them but I'm-
I'm getting better about the things so I should have this well handled in just a bit if-if the
elements of my room don't bother me. Oh frick I don't know what to do- oh shit my power I forgot about the weasel!
Forgot about the weasel. Okay-er the badger! The badger and the weasel are gonna kick my ass now!
Fuck I'm dead oh!
Where are the ladies? I don't really know now! You will kill me I know that is true yeah!
I really bel- Ah there you are, okay. Found you guys.
Found you.
Okay well they got a lot of pieces oh i got you okay got you Just in time
[I have corrected some mistakes in the captions up until this point, so if someone could please correct the rest or as much as you can that would be greatly appreciated, thank you.]
okay so i Just got to keep the heat
on this one
Hopefully hold them in place so he's going to the birthday room all right now I got a-better now I got a better thing.
Got a better way of it. Then camera..
Heat! Okay got a better way I don't know what he's going to but it's probably the side right room- nope, left- no
Ah!
It was that one he just didn't get there yet
okay
i got this Kind of Maintain This for five Minutes
No, oh almost Missed that. Oh? So i've got
I've Got a New strategy where if i know What room is going into i don't
Quite Know Which Room that is i think It might Be This one but if i know Which Room it is
Beforehand i can leave it on that before i go look and Try to get my panic down this is one Thing
To save me Just a small
Amount of time If he's going to the birthday room so i switch into the birthday Room and then i flip back and forth There
Until i see him heat that up
You Guys Hear that i think it's fine slowly fine everything's fine
Happy Birthday ah
Not that oh i really Fucked it oh i fucked it up i got the wrong vent
Oh shit i don't know if They're still gonna be there
Stay There Ladies See there look hey Why'd you say uh okay thank you for being Very accommodating
okay everything's fine My Power My Power Yellow Get Out of There She's What if i fuck that up
Yeah There's Every Possibility
Oh god Where's oh God Damn did he are to get the piece i think you already Got the piece i wasn't Paying Attention
Yes he did oh no is that the Loki's Very Few okay very few
Very Few Pieces so he can afford i can afford That One You Cd sure you bill
All right Whatever
Oops You all right so i Just Got a
These Guys are these Girls come on Bring me another element give me my Win?
Give me my win i earned It i'm a Good Boy
I'm a Good robot i know that i'm a Robot I'm pretty sure i'm a role a
Fuck I'm Pretty sure Just Clicked outside the game i thought Was go crazy
There we Go i'm good i'm good i
can't imagine how fast Weasley's gonna be weaseling His way Through Town
When he's going at full sprint
Like That Shit
Now
That Thing by my Foot is still there by the Way i haven't forgotten about that i've Just Been Ignoring it you shh
I don't know what it is i think it's another piece of foam that fell off
okay Good
Huh what did you Get for me what are we gonna do in the horror Show of Horror Land oh Hey Badger Badger Badger
Are you looking for you gonna look for foxy because i remember where foxy be
Down in the Dark Secrets of This World That i remember i
remember i think i remember off to the right Right
Maybe I'm not ever Seem too sure but i think and maybe That's Where it was
Yes Am i gonna find a hook a lost hook Amid the myriad oh, oh no this Was mangle
There's bits Everywhere
Not sure what that means i Mean from angle i think i know what i mean oh?
mangle You Dropped your Head your other Head i mean
so where's foxy
She's the Only one that i haven't Really Seen in here i'm a Go okay alright see you?
Or maybe no these are all the Toy Ones That's Right
It was that mangle is the toy foxy oh these are all The Toys?
Okay well let me let me rush into a Death we're gonna find out Exactly What's going on here and then we're gonna
Deal With it
With you yeah for me give me the lure
What the fuck is the Black Rabbit What is the Black Rabbit
Call The White rabbit i know about That
Answer the goddamn phone already
Fritz: Nice work kid. Only a few days left of your shift.
Fritz: Maybe if you're super good, I'll let you mess around in my office, try out some of WeaselWare's features.
Though, it’s not that exciting. You might be able to control the gang and see what they can do. I don’t know, maybe not. We’ll see.
I’m wondering... since I can’t remember how much I’ve taught you up to this point... do you know about Freddy Fazbear’s Pizza?
Mark [Sarcastic]: Wuh? What? Huh?
Fritz: I think these calls might be getting to my head but I dunno.
F: I've been thinking of that place a lot more than usual for the past hour or so.
Not in a disturbing or scary sense, just... I’m not sure. It's like some pieces are being put together.
Freddy Fazbear... [Fritz chuckles] Y'know they used to say those characters were haunted.
There were some murders related to the location back in the 80’s. People found some corpses buried in the animatronic suits. Really sad.
I was a fan of that franchise, named my kid after one of the characters there. Not because I was a fan really, but because...
Well, because I wanted to love that name again.
After... Y'know... (sighs) it doesn't matter.
I was a fan of the restaurant and it hurt to see it fall so morbidly, that’s all. I wonder sometimes if there was some kind of moral reasoning
behind whoever killed those kids.
I have my own suspicions as do hundreds of other people, y'know? You should see what these people put online.
There’s a popular theory going around that the guy who did it had purple skin. Totally purple skin and purple clothes.
Sounds like a demon or something, right? Something paranormal. I don’t know.
But around that time is when I got help from someone in the hospital. We, uh, don’t know where the blood came from.
It’s all… what if he… What if it was him? Oh god, this is ridiculous. I'm sorry.
I-It’s times like these where the nightmares sometimes visit me during the day. [Interrupted by Mark] Ask me a question then. It might calm me down.
Mark: HI OH OKAY ALRIGHT THAT'S NO GOOD I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO WHHHY ARE YOU DOING I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO MEEEEE
Fritz: -they were a big thing over there. Every kid-
Mark: I don't know what happened to meeee
F: -loved living near one and almost every one I was friends with had some kind of toy of a character.
It was a great place which is primarily why I started working there. I uh... (sigh) god… I worked at Freddy Fazbear’s, yes.
Though it was many, many years ago, mind you. They had loads of different locations, more than an average independent restaurant.
Each building had an exclusive character which had its own toy, I think. It was like a collection thing so the kids had to go to every Freddy Fazbear’s in the area to finish the set of figurines or plushies or whatever.
It was clever and I’m sure it did wonders for them money-wise, but I can’t help but wonder how sad the system would have been for a child on the poorer side of town.
Although the characters had smaller cameo editions based on the restaurant you were in and they were always the main four guys
whom which were in the adverts and on the billboards and on the pizza boxes of course.
Freddy Fazbear, obviously, Chica the Chicken, Foxy the Fox and there was also, uh… a bunny rabbit called Bonnie.
These four characters were huge where I lived, way bigger than Ronald McDonald or Colonel Sanders, you know?
My past with the location is pretty personal, so I’d rather not go on about it. Not that I’m hiding anything from you; it’s more for my own sake.
Markiplier: Sure, okay yeah let's go with that
Fritz: I... don’t really like to talk about that anymore, not even to my daughter.
F: I’m sure that from the figurines around the location, you can guess that I own quite a lot. See you tomorrow.
Okay so we've got another Rogue element in the mix i have to watch Out for this Asshole
Good What about the Black Rabbit It Says Stop the Black Rabbit i don't know What you Mean by That
Shit oh
Frickin Dick Mr. Mogae
This is falling apart at The seams oh
Ah you lied to me what Does that Mean?
Are you we Will kill you, oh?
i forgot about the vent ah
Rick oh i have no idea where they are oh? I have nine to eight apparently. Oh?
you Asshole
What do i do about That
What fuck you i'm gonna look at the window you're gonna
Panic
You've died something Else apparently i'm gonna die to panic Barely Here comes a Panic
Poppy Poopy
I can't move i
can't see this is cool you're a
Bye
I'll Just wait Here don't Mind me i'll be here dying
So Anyway that fell apart quickly but i think i'll be Able to Handle this i should Be Able to beat This in the next
episode I'm Pretty Sure - All the other bullshit Because i know it's not five
Ever so thank you everybody so much for watching Let me know what you think
as Always
In the next video Bye?